[Music] what's up guys How We Do you guys looking
forward to the game tonight or what my
mom's right here she loves [Laughter]
you y y let's go let's [Applause] [Music]
[Applause] go
who was your childhood hockey hero my childhood
hockey hero had to be CL I'm very now lucky to
be able to play with them uh mine was Gary
Roberts Growing Up played for the Toronto
map police where I where I grew up what is the
best part about playing in the NHL I think the
best part is being able to come to an event like
this we've had this trip circled on our calendars
for a long time so it's reason why he play is to
create memories for everybody all right we got a
special guest here to do the lineup St on right
wing Drake Bry Max the the big Force [Applause]
birk oh [Applause] [Music] yeah
lell sweeps in shoot scores and
Florida takes the early lead there you go by he
scores and it's a one-1 tie oh
there you go [Music] [Applause]
kid let's go baby let's go the Ottawa
Senators went by a final score of 4-2
on a big night for Jake B buddy this
is awesome this what it's all about
the TR bille you come out and get into
the communities and never forget this
day